[Music]
Oh what is going on YouTube now recently
a subscriber asked how come I will see
everybody's Facebook updated their life
is so much more exciting than mine how
do I get there you know surprise me you
are not the first person I heard this
from did I see it a lot of people
compare the lies to someone else's from
what they've seen on Facebook and I got
to tell you something back to time it's
all [ __ ] but I'll save that topic
for the next plus so before we get into
that let's talk about this whole thing
I'll let's just say for example that
these people are actually living that
don't lie they pop the champagne bottles
off the supermodels below they lick in a
whipped cream homage a little Georgia
Peach booty cheeks oh can I ask you this
if you want to live an exciting life
what [ __ ] are you always on Facebook huh
you don't have that time people who
complain that they have nothing to do
tend not to do [ __ ] in general nothing
about what I just said instead of
sitting there being a dick like you're
holding it for ransom why don't you go
up and do something oh god did I just
give us a notion to a problem holy [ __ ]
what Paul again you know a few feet you
dig that much eventually it's gonna
fight back watch you reach for your dick
and it'd be like not today [ __ ]
listen you cannot complain that you have
nothing to do when all you do is lay in
your room with your thumb again get up
and use your [ __ ] legs my god
[ __ ] there are people in
wheelchairs looking at you like what you
would think that the amount of time that
you have spent on your computer
complaining about your [ __ ] that you
would find something to do do you
realize that half your time is spent on
their as wandering and complaining why
you can't have what other people have
and yes I understand there are certain
limitations and I'm not talking about
those type of people I'm not saying that
if you can you should be you know riding
a giraffe [ __ ] the hippo and punching
a [ __ ] dolphin in the stomach you
listen not every single life experience
has to be extravagant not everything has
to cost money but you do have to make
the conscious effort and actually do
things something about it there's only
so much that you can do chilling in your
bedroom before you realize that you
actually have to go and make your
memories and you know I always hear that
same [ __ ] excuse the cities we live
with this food [ __ ] boring I wish I
lived in LA
it don't matter where you live you gonna
be doing the same [ __ ] here that you
were doing over there
you move a dumbass from one place to
another is just an idiot in a different
location but you guys always hear me say
the same saying life is always what you
make it but it's up to you to take what
you deserve
so having said that if you want to have
experiences to share with the world you
got to go out and have life experiences
this is common sense and then just me oh
my god
go outside fight and lock this monster
Hut that [ __ ] [ __ ] and ride
that [ __ ] like a cowboy we in 2015
I've already set a goal I'm gonna find
me a unicorn and I'm a whisper 30 things
that has something to say or this weird
story to tell because when I'm not
writing or doing work or taking meetings
I'm doing more than just sitting in my
[ __ ] room wondering what the [ __ ]
everybody else is doing when I was
younger I had a lot more free time I
went outside I talk to people I
experienced weird things because I get
things out of my comfort zone thus I
have more experiences to talk about get
your hands out your chair and go do
something get off your social media
[ __ ]
live and do something get off of youtube
stop nope you stay on watch my [ __ ] and
then get off I've heard many people
comparing the whoopsie I've heard many
people comparing their lives of what
they see on other people's fake epic
enough what are you saying you dumbass
kill him